Chevreuse en mode La Rochelle dans son
sixième de finale de championnat de
France de régional une comme les
Rochelais dans leur finale européenne
face aux Irlandais du Leicester les
chevrotins encaissent un 17 à 0 contre
Créteil dans les 20 premières minutes de
la rencontre une pénalité et deux essais
encaissées la domination est sans
partage
on est rentré sur le terrain à mort quoi
et eux c'est arrivé plein d'envies on
s'est fait voilà on s'est fait rouler
dessus pendant 20 minutes quoi il y a
pas grand chose à dire on a on a mis la
main sur le ballon comme il l'avait fait
et après on a pu avancer et dérouler le
jeu donc on n'a pas le ballon c'est
compliqué quoi les Yvelinois vont
finalement se réveiller il franchissent
une première fois la ligne en force
et sur une belle inspiration les liée de
Chevreuse fait la différence
[Applaudissements]
les chevrotins recollent au score à la
mi-temps ils ont 6 points de retard
Créteil mène 20 à 14 au retour des
vestiaires Chevreuse garde la même
dynamique le rouleau compresseur
Chevrotin est enclenché
les Yvelines définitivement l'avantage
grâce à cet essai 20 à 24
Chevreuse prend même le large en fin de
match jusqu'à s'imposer sur le score de
43 à 20
en deuxième mi-temps là on n'a pas lâché
les 30 et on a réussi à revenir sur les
fondamentaux quoi vraiment devant avec
deux essais sur ballon porter et voilà
quoi on arrive à trouver deux bonnes
sorties de camp et après et après
surtout de se faire plaisir quoi de
mettre du combat parce que le rugby ça
commence par le combat et si on n'en met
pas on gagnera pas de match quoi donc
ils ont décidé eux en deuxième mi-temps
de mettre du combat et voilà un huitième
de finale de régionale une Chevreuse
affrontera l'us-sainte rugby un club de
Charente-Maritime qui sera forcément
gonflé à bloc après le titre de champion
d'Europe de La Rochelle les chevrotins
sont prévenus
[Applaudissements]